a medida que pasa el tiempo los días y
las horas la tensión en Turquía aumenta
a medida que se van recuperando
cadáveres desde los fondos de los
escombros de los servicios de ruidos
como este en la ciudad de adana hace
unos minutos los equipos de rescate han
sacado desde debajo de las runas este
coche completamente destrozado y también
ha venido una vecina de este lugar que
explicaba que su padre sigue ahí dentro
después de todas esas horas estaba
visiblemente enfada de tensionada con
los equipos de rescate que asegura ella
que están haciendo un show une para las
cámaras pero que en realidad dice ella
no hace nada La verdad es que llevan
estos equipos de rescate día y noche
entero sin dormir trabajando para
intentar sacar al mayor número de
personas con vida que lo Consigna
algunas ocasiones en cuentagotas salen
algunas personas comidas sin embargo
cada vez a medida que avanzan los días y
las horas estas personas que consiguen
salir comidas son menos en comparación
con los cadáveres rescatados de debajo
de los escombros sin embargo hay muchos
lugares en Turquía y también en el norte
de Siria donde estos equipos de rescate
no han llegado son sobre todo pueblos de
mediano y pequeño tamaño allí muchos
vecinos han sido los responsables para
sacar a sus seres queridos y sus vecinos
de debajo de los escombros con muy malos
resultados según nos han explicado ellos
mismos en días anteriores se quejaban de
que el gobierno Turco en algunos casos
concretos algunas ciudades y pueblos les
ha dejado completamente abandonados